Let's start by considering just these first two terms, x squared plus 6x, and we
want to complete the square with these 2 terms as the first 2 terms of that
squared polynomial. Then the constant we need to add at the end is 9, since 6
over 2 is 3 and 3 squared is 9. However, if we want to add 9 inside here,
without actually adding anything total to either side of the quation, then we
need to talso subtract 9 from somewhere on the right side. So that's exactly
what I did. I wrote plus 9 inside the parenthesis, and then a minus 9 next to
the plus 3 outside. Remember that because all of these terms are just added
together, these parenthesis here are really just for notation. They're just to
help me visualize that these terms belong together. This doesn't, in any way,
change the way these terms are combined. The factored form of x squared plus 6x
plus 9 is x plus 3 squared, and negative 9 plus 3 is just minus 6. So the
completed square form of y equals x squared plus 6x plus 3 is y equals the
quantity x plus 3 squared minus 6.